d'appeler en toute amitié oui pour
benjamin si vous avez envie qu'on
l'appelle on peut l'appeler allez c'est
parti on l'appelle à on l'appelle on va
voir si répond patrick timsit
comme ça au moins on aura une
explication vous avez vu le décès mais
c'était plutôt sympa oui c'est que de la
vanille de vérité c'est une farce
allô allô oui c'est pas lui a lui appris
qu à ben patrick timsit
oui c'est bien patrick timsit
c'est patrick bourgeois
non c'est assez c'est cyril hanouna
c'est pourquoi service et ça va bien
patrick qu'est ce qui t'a pesci on n'a
pas compris en fait j'ai vu que vous
avez vannes et payer en ligne avec les
mêmes et non mais si tu as un truc
contre nous dit nous s'est passé est
long mais mais mais tu sais ce que c'est
tenter les banques ne fait pas un petit
peu le saumon balle tu sais pas remarqué
quoi mais bon même temps j'ai pas
vraiment montré plus en plus c'est quand
même un peu le bordel tomber millions
mais bon pas si la facture travaillée
texte patrick hein et quand on tombe
chez toi vous êtes ans compte pas même
est monté de laval montréal et est sûre
bajaras everett est un peu dur benjamin
castaldi baertschi pas benjamin griveaux
[Rires]
il reconnaît vrai j'ai rien contre toi
mais bunge excuse moi mais ça à vrai
dire il ya autant je l'aimé bien avant
et là tu espères en pierre de lave
derrière plein naufrage
mais patrick a tu continues alors ça
veut dire tu t'arrêtes jamais en fait
non il faut tenue en fait t'as mais
quand on voit la qualité prix
il n'y aurait pourtant on demande quand
j'étais plus drôle et et qu'on en fait
c'est ça l'histoire mais c'était d'avion
en fait des livres du congrès si des
méchants c'est un peu près jamais
concédée c'est ça c'est sûr que c'est
pas moi qui ai croisé monte à tour mois
vite quand on prenait 20 minutes
haletantes et une émission maintenant tu
te convient cyril le ton ta tombe assez
drôle c'était des jolies femmes âgées
mais c'est pas drôle ça le problème est
que toi en fait l'idée ridicule non plus
tenu des lunettes de galles alors que
pas du tout à elle complètement benjamin
et cogema
on n'élit pas la loi répond d'abord une
habitante l'attenté soit comme un promo
j'ai dû rentrer ça serait très bien
alors c'est monsieur nenê ça et on peut
mettre en scène un conte et des cours
d'eau ont prévu de taxer les tons
mettant en fin de match 2 des pompes à
la presse que tu as dit rapatrie nombre
et du tout c'est stupide ce qu'il dit ou
alors c'est pas lui c'est si c'est lui
je trouve ça très triste
j'irai probablement nombreux mais ouais
ouais ouais mais tout arrive mais c'est
vrai que c'est pas très gentil ce que tu
as dit en fait mais c'est pas
aujourd'hui mais quand on se verra on
pourrait expliquer tous les deux si tu
votes pour les millions je viens héros
p14 ménagers pam a offert à kate sait
mais on va pas me faire inquiète nous
avons se croiser un jour patrick et le
ridicule ne tue pas ben là c'est surtout
quand tu serais mort depuis longtemps
c'est sûr on va nous dire tout ce qu'il
fait c'est pas drôle là c'est la seule
phrase que j'aime passer de trucs sur ma
famille ça mon petit gars ça passera pas
voilà je vois pas si dsk baulchois
j'aime pas
j'aime pas énervé j'aime pas j'aime pas
voilà ça me rappelle ce qu'on guillon
laquelle médias même chose calmez-vous
vachement non mais là alors patrick
autant brasse sabots j'embrasse pas du
tout entendre d'ailleurs non non je
t'emmerde
je suis désolé c'est hyper irrespectueux
benjamin genêt riz peut pas dire que
benjamin écrit un livre sur ses
grands-parents ou qu'il aime d'amour
juste pour faire doubler je veux dire un
monde si la belle est venu là bas ce
sera il s'est révélé telle qu'il est sur
mon aigri méchant et pas drôle mais
c'est pas là oh là là qu occupait de ton
festival carapatte aura plus que ça à
[ __ ] allez vas-y